- If you're good at what you
do, people will recognize that.
From grade one to six
you're in this one school.
And then you go to this new school.
I went to this new school,
and there was this girl.
This girl named Sandy.
I stopped listening to
music after Kurt died
because it was so
emotional just hearing it.
I love being a drummer.
It's such a nice position in a band.
Everyone thinks you're dumb.
I can truthfully say
aloud that Gangnam Style
is one of my favorite
songs of the past decade.
- He's an American rock musician,
singer, songwriter, director and producer.
He's best known as the former drummer
of the grunge band Nirvana,
and founder and front man of
the rock band Foo Fighters.
In 2012, he was estimated to be
the third wealthiest drummer in the world
with a fortune of $225 million.
He's Dave Grohl, and here's my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number eight is my personal favorite,
and I'm curious to figure out
which one you guys like the best,
As you're watching Dave,
if he says something
really meaningful to you,
make sure to put it in
quotes in the comments below
so other people can be inspired as well.
- If you're good at what you
do, people will recognize that.
I really believe it.
I really believe that going out
and playing good songs live
as a great live band
will make you successful.
I really think it will.
And it doesn't matter if you're at the--
down the street or you're on
the side stage of Bonnaroo
or you're headlining Lalapalooza.
If you're a great band with great songs,
people will notice it.
That's it, that's all it is.
It's that simple.
- - product placement
and labels and A&R people
and all that--
It doesn't-- matter.
I swear to God it doesn't matter.
If you back that up with the idea
that just playing those great songs
in your great live band
is enough reward for you then you're set.
But you've got to be badass.
You just have to be really good.
It's the other things
that make up for your musical inability.
As a drummer, I never felt like,
I'm going to be on the cover
of Modern Drummer magazine
because I'm the best drummer in the world.
I just knew that if you put me on stage
without a PA or floor
monitors in a small club,
that I would beat the-- out of my drums
so much that people would go,
Goddamn, did you see that-- drummer?
- Right.
- Whoa.
And I walk away from every
show like, there you go.
I just beat the piss out of
those things and people saw it.
- People took notice for sure.
- And that was great!
So at the end of the show I
was as successful musician.
Because I had achieved
what I wanted to achieve.
So I honestly believe it.
I know lots of musicians that went down to
South by Southwest and said
well that's easy for you to say.
Man, I was in the same position
you are in 24 years ago.
That was it.
I worked at a furniture warehouse
and I wanted people to like my music
so I played out as much as I could.
If you really, honestly, like I said,
if you're passionate and driven
and focused in what you do,
if you're really good at
it, people will take notice.
That's basically it.
I don't understand the industry.
I don't understand where music is headed.
I don't really understand technology.
I just know that when you walk into a club
and you see a band that blows you away,
you are going to follow that band.
You're either going to buy their CD
or you're going to find them online
or you're going to see them the
next time they come to play.
That's what it takes.
You don't have to stand in
line at the song contest on TV
to become a popular musician.
To stand in front of some judge
that doesn't even play an instrument
on their own Goddamn record
telling you you're not good enough-- that.
Go blow people away in their face.
I honestly believe it's that simple.
I directed music videos
before for The Foo Fighters.
I mean, it's easy.
I honestly believe that if you're focused
and passionate and driven,
you can achieve anything
you want to achieve in life.
I honestly believe that.
Because you'll figure it out.
So I never took lessons to play the drums.
I just figured it out.
I never to lessons to play guitar.
I took maybe a few, but I just
listened to Beatles records.
I would listen and practice
by myself in my bedroom obsessively.
Throughout life, I've
always kind of figured
that that's just how you do stuff.
Like if you have a natural inclination
and a real drive to do something,
that you can figure it out.
- Was playing the guitar your real dream,
your childhood dream?
Kind of, because when I
was about 11 years old
I was in I think seventh grade.
From grade one to six,
you're in this one school.
And then you go to this new school.
I went to this new school
and there was this girl.
This girl named Sandy.
Oh she was so beautiful.
She had big blue eyes and this
perfect heart shaped face.
I was instantly in love with this chick.
So the first day I asked her,
"Want to go steady with me?"
She was like, "Okay"
So every day I'd meet her at her locker
and we'd kiss at the locker
and then she'd get on her
bus and I'd get on my bus
and we'd go home and talk on the phone.
After seven days, she said,
"You know, I'm new here
"and I just don't want to get tied down."
We were like 11 years old.
(laughter)
"I don't want to get tied
into a relationship."
It absolutely broke my heart.
I was heartbroken.
And that night I had a dream
that I was in an arena full of people
and I was playing guitar.
It's this packed arena and
they're all going, "Yeah!"
I'm playing and I look down
and she's staring at me
and she's crying.
(audience applause)
- Revenge (laughs).
- My rock 'n roll revenge.
You could have been my girlfriend.
- We all have this dream
but we just don't end up
like The Foo Fighters,
that's the problem.
- Dreams come true.
Honestly, making albums
to tape, it's easy.
I think that people get scared because
there's so much emphasis
put on perfection now
that that's why people use computers.
If you're a drummer and
you speed up a little bit
or you slow down a little bit,
you throw it in the computer
and make it sound perfect.
Then if you sang a little
bit sharp or a little flat,
you can smooth all of that out.
And it just makes it sound--
you lose all the
personality and character.
Imagine if you Pro Tooled a Who record.
It wouldn't sound like The Who.
It's like, wow that's tape.
That's Monkey Wrench.
- That's Monkey Wrench?
That's incredible.
- It's cool, you know?
With computers, they're
great for some things.
But when it comes to making
a raw rock 'n roll record,
you just can't beat it.
You got to just go with tape.
I stopped listening to
music after Kurt died
because it was so
emotional just hearing it.
I didn't want to hear it on the radio.
I didn't want to play it.
I didn't want to join another band.
Then after awhile I realized
that it was the one thing
that was going to help me
get through everything.
So I started writing lyrics,
I started writing songs.
And I went and recorded this demo tape.
("Big Me")
A record company called and said,
"Hey we want to release your record."
And I said, "That's a
demo, that's not a band.
"It's a thing I did by
myself in five days."
- You played every instrument?
- Yeah, so then I started to think,
wow maybe I will try this.
I've never been the singer of a band.
- Was it a tough transition
from drummer to front man?
- Absolutely, it took years, man.
It look a long time.
The most important thing is
that, whatever you're doing,
that it's a representation of your voice.
Say you're using a computer
or you're using an oboe
or you're a drummer
or a vocalist, whatever it is.
The most important thing is
that it's really your voice.
That it's coming from you.
But it has to come from you.
It's so easy just to
grab a loop and hit play
and let it do its thing.
- - that, that's somebody else's loop.
That's somebody else's beat, man.
Make your own beat.
Take that guys beat,
step on it and-- it up
and then put it out
there, make it your own.
You do that.
I have always loved, whether
it's like Kraftwerk--
I was one of the first
dorks in my neighborhood
to get a Prodigy record.
In like 1990 or whatever
year it was, or '91.
I didn't have a pacifier and a glow stick.
(audience laughter)
But I liked the idea.
Thank you very much.
I liked the idea that these
people were doing something new.
It didn't matter if it was as
a computer or a drum machine.
It was something new, it was really cool.
But lately, what is that?
The last two days I had pool
parties for my kid's friends.
My wife turns on Pandora
to the Blockbuster Hits station.
It was like apocalyptic.
I was terrified.
I was like, the human race is going down
such a dangerous path.
We're all going to die.
Everyone's worried about asteroids.
- - that, turn on the radio.
That will scare the-- out of you.
I listen to that and I
just don't hear anyone.
It's like two stupid people
talking to each other.
There's just nothing there.
It's devoid of anything.
How could that be?
It's terrible.
(audience laughter)
So the most important thing (laughs)
I honestly think,
is you have to be able to take
whatever it is that someone else is using
and make it your own.
Or just do your own thing.
I love being a drummer.
It's such a nice position in a band.
Everyone thinks you're dumb.
What they don't realize is that
if it weren't for you,
their band would suck.
(laughs)
I've always loved being the drummer.
I don't necessarily need
to be the dude out front.
I never imagined myself a front man.
At the same time, I don't
mind bringing the party
to 85,000 people at the lip of the stage
being the front man of the band.
It's nice to have both.
There's that balance between the two.
If you ever start feeling like
nobody's paying attention to me.
When then you go and sing in
The Foo Fighters for awhile.
Then when you're like,
Goddamn I'm sick of all this--
go back to being the drummer
in The Vultures or whatever.
It's weird, as a musician,
you want to be great.
You want to be good.
And you sort of set these funny
expectations for yourself.
One of the funniest things
that Fogarty ever said to me,
He was like, "Yeah, I was
learning to play the drums
"but I realized that I
would never be as good
"as John Bonham from Led
Zeppelin, so I stopped."
Who is as good as John? Nobody.
Like, what the-- how could you do that?
There should be no right or wrong.
You should just be cool with
what you do and how you sound.
It's one of the things that
I have a problem with a lot
of those song contest shows on TV.
Not only because it's
corporate cheese or whatever.
But I have a problem with, like
if my kid walked up on stage
and sang her heart out
as best as she could,
and Jennifer Lopez said, "No,
sorry that's not good enough."
I would be so pissed.
Because that's not how it works.
You should go to a yard
sale and buy an old guitar.
Then go find a friend and
get them in your garage
and then just suck and be awful.
And then write some songs
and become the biggest band in the world.
(audience cheers)
Because that's how it works.
It works other ways too, I'm sure.
As a young musician, first of all,
you're not going to
make a living doing it.
Accept that, realize that.
Because then if you do, you're stoked.
The reward of playing music,
playing music should be the
reward of playing music.
That's what you get.
When I was a little kid,
or when I was playing
punk rock music as a teenager,
there was never any career opportunity
because we played punk rock music.
Nobody wanted to buy that.
But we loved to do it.
It was so much fun.
If you start from a place like that.
That you just love to create
and you just love to play music
and you can't stop thinking about it
and you do it every day
and you do it by yourself
or you do it with your friends.
And that's enough for you
to survive the rest of
your life, that's great.
Then once you start getting good,
you start playing for people.
And once you start playing for people
if you're good, then those
people will tell other people,
"That band's really good"
So then all of a sudden you're playing
to all these different people.
That to me is the most important thing.
When it's you on stage.
When people see another person doing that,
it's really inspiring.
It's cool just to see a human
being jamming, that's great.
Guilt, guilt is cancer.
It will confine you.
Torture you.
Destroy you as an artist.
It's a wall, it's a
black hole, it's a thief.
It will keep you from you.
Remember learning your first song or riff
or writing your first lyric?
There was no guilt then.
Remember when there was no right or wrong?
Remember that simple reward
of just playing music?
You are still and will always be
that person at your core.
The musician.
And the musician comes first.
- - guilty pleasure.
How about, just pleasure?
I can truthfully say
aloud that Gangnam Style
is one of my favorite
songs of the past decade.
(audience laughter)
(audience applause)
It is.
Is it any better or worse than
the latest Atoms for Peace album?
Hmm.
If only we had a celebrity panel of judges
to determine that for us.
What would J Lo do?
Paging Pitchfork, come
in, come in, Pitchfork,
we need you to help us determine
the value of a song.
Who-- cares.
(audience applause)
Who is to say what's a good voice
and what's not a good voice?
The Voice?
(audience laughter)
Imagine Bob Dylan standing there
singing Blowing in the Wind
in front of Christina Aguilera.
(audience laughter)
Mmm, I think you sound a
little nasally and sharp.
(audience laughter)
It's your voice.
Cherish it, respect it, nurture it.
Challenge it, stretch it,
scream it until it's gone.
Because everyone's blessed
with at least that.
And who knows how long it will last.
- Whether he's playing protective dad,
or Rock God,
Dave Grohl is exactly
where he wants to be.
♫ Is someone getting the
best, the best, the best
♫ The best of you
- People talk about the good old days.
Well-- that, man, this is great.
- Do you ever think, I
want to do something else?
- Nope, I don't know
how to do anything else.
This is it.
♫ You trust, you must confess
♫ Getting the best, the best, the best
♫ Best of you
I just love it.
It's really, really great.
That sounds like-- but it's true (laughs)
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Stuart Beale asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which
of Dave's top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
What change you're going to make
in your business or in your life.
Leave it in the comments
and I will join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give a quick shout out
to Michael T. Cole.
Michael, thank you so
much for buying my book.
It really means a lot to me.
For those of you watching,
if you want your chance at a shout out
in a future video, make sure to
pick up a copy of the book
and email in the receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe
or whatever your one word is.
And I'll see you soon.
(swoosh)
- Hold on, hold on a second.
Shh, quiet, ah, stop, stop.
No no no no no no no no no.
You don't fight at my show, you--
Who's that right there, let me see him.
Who's fighting right now?
Who's fighting?
Let me see him.
It's that guy in the
striped shirt right there.
Hey, look at you!
Hey, look at me!
Hey, in the striped shirt,
look at me right here.
Look at me, look at me.
Get the-- out of my show right now.
Get the-- out.
Get the-- out of my show.
Get the -- out of my show right now.
You don't come to my show and fight.
You come to my show and dance, you--
(crowd cheers)
Get the-- out of here.
I'm not going to put up with that--
You people came here to have a good time.
Not put up with--
(crowd cheers)
I think I just broke my leg.
(crowd boos)
I think I really broke my leg.
So look, you have my promise, right now,
that The Foo Fighters,
we're going to come back
and finish this show.
But right now,
you got to do, show me
on the monitor right now.
You got to do it.
Can you do it?
(crowd cheers)
Ladies and gentlemen,
let me tell you,
right now, I'm going
to go to the hospital.
I'm going to fix my leg.
And then I'm going to come back
and we're going to play for you again.
I'm so sorry.
We're going to do it.
But right now, Taylor Hawkins.
You got to do it, you got to do it.
(crowd cheers)
(crowd chants Dave, Dave, Dave)
- So listen up, so listen up you all.
Dave just broke his leg in a big way.
So we're not going to do a
Foo Fighters show tonight
but he really wants us,
because we love him so much,
he wants us to play a
couple songs for you guys.
Now they're not going to
be Foo Fighters songs.
We're just going to have a
little bit of fun with you guys.
Just do a couple songs before we go.
Do you want us to do that?
(crowd cheers)
Are you sure?
Let's do this for Dave, okay.
We're not going to do a whole long set
but we're going to play
a couple songs for you.
Just a couple party songs.
Then we're going to come back with Dave.
It won't be tonight but we'll come back
and we'll play to all of you guys
and we'll do an even longer
Foo Fighters show, okay?
(crowd cheers)
We love you, Dave!
(crowd repeats)
All he was doing was busting
his ass for you guys.
We're going to play a couple songs.
We're going to have a little bit of fun.
And then you guys go
home and get home early.
But we're going to come back, okay?
Do you want to hear a
couple songs for fun?
(crowd cheers)
♫ Let me out
♫ Pray tomorrow gets me higher
♫ Day day de mm hm
♫ Da da da ba ba
♫ Chipping around, kick
my brains around the floor
♫ These are the days it
never rains but it pours
♫ Ee do ba be
♫ Ee da ba ba ba
♫ Um bo bo
♫ Be lap
♫ People on streets
♫ Ee da de da de
♫ Ee da de da de da de da
♫ It's the terror of knowing
what the world is about
♫ Watching some good friends screaming
♫ Let me out
♫ Pray tomorrow gets
me higher, higher, high
♫ Pressure on people, people on streets
♫ Turned away from it all like a blind man
♫ Sat on a fence but it don't work
♫ Keep coming up with love
but it's so slashed and torn
♫ Why, why, why?
♫ Love, love, love, love, love
♫ Insanity laughs under
pressure we're breaking
♫ Can't we give ourselves one more chance?
♫ Why can't we give love
that one more chance?
♫ Why can't we give love, give
love, give love, give love
♫ Give love, give love, give
love, give love, give love?
♫ Because love's such
an old fashioned word
♫ And love dares you to care for
♫ The people on the edge of the night
♫ People on streets
♫ And love dares you to change our way of
♫ Caring about ourselves
♫ This is our last dance
♫ This is ourselves under pressure
♫ Under pressure
♫ Pressure